[موسيقى]
رياح عاتيه فيضانات وانهيارات ارضيه
وزوابع لم يسلم منها حجر ولا بشر كان حدثا
مهولا واجهه سكان جمهوريه هايتي ومحيطها
في اكتوبر للعام 2016 انه اعصار ماثيو
الذي خلف اكثر من 1000 ضحيه واضر باكثر من
مليونين شخص فما قصته بدا اعصار ماثيوك
موجه استوائيه نشات قباله الساحل الغربي
لافريقيا في الخامسه والعشرين من سبتمبر
لعام 2016 ثم اتجه غربا عبر المحيط
الاطلنطي بالقرب من منطقه الكاريبي وسواحل
جنوب شرق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انتقلت المنطقه فورا الى حاله الطوارئ
وصنف الاعصار بالفئه الخامسه مع رياح
بسرعه 160 ميلا في الساعه ثم تراجعت قوته
الى الفئه الرابعه
اطلقت سفارات الانذار وطلب من سكان
المناطق القريبه اخلاءها وخلال ايام قليله
كان اعصار ماثيو الثائر يصب غضبه على
جمهوريه هايت وشرق كوبا ثم اجتاح غرب
جزيره بهاما وسوذكر لاينا وفلوريدا في
الولايات المتحده ايضا جنوب غرب هيئه
اعتبر المنطقه الاكثر تضررا حيث بدا فيها
الاعصار قبل ان ينتشر في انحاء الدوله
الفقيره التي كانت تعاني ايضا من انتشار
وباء الكوليرا ما اربك سلطات هناك
الشرب بالبلاد ودمر 90% من المحاصيل
مئات الالاف من المنازل تضررت او دمرت
واعتبر
بنسبه 90% استمره طول الامطار الغزيره على
المسار بين هيت وكوبر ثم امتدت العاصفه
الى شواطئ امريكا الجنوبيه تاثر اكثر من
73 الف شكر بطريقه ما بالفيضانات او
العاديه
وتقطعت السبل بالاف الاشخاص في من قطعت
خدمات الماء والكهرباء
تضررت العديد من المنازل والطرق
بالفياضانات والانهيارات الارضيه وابلغ عن
خسائر زراعيه باكثر من 85%
نسبه نحو الف حاله الى الاعصار مع ما يقرب
من 500 حاله وفاه في هايتي وحدها تم اطلاق
النداء العاجل للحصول على 119 مليون دولار
امريكي
عدد المتضررين باكثر من مليونين شخص منهم
مليون و400,000 بحاجه الى مساعدات عاجله
كما قدرت حجم المساعدات الاداريه المطلوبه
للتعافي بنحو مليونين و700,000 دولار
امريكي على مدى ثلاث سنوات
كان يعصروا ماثيو اكثر الاعاصير عنفا في
منطقه المحيط الاطلسي منذ اعصار ستان في
عام 2005 لكنه شكل ايضا ماساه اضافيه
لمجموعه من الماسه التي يعيشها سكان هايتي
والمناطق القريبه منها
[موسيقى]